[Music]
my name is jordi a live in the with the
lens in rotterdam and on by in hamburg
the earlier send and
[Music]
to me to you go buddy the family
important in porn substance for donnie and
and all your mind and the  drink it
with ajax online tank and open it up and the
centro the underground
and play with
[Music]
and one on the toilet piazza della vita
is a play the complete molds
ze water square at people a go in bar
in a girlfriend
seat  and who and who underline her
the actors a plane role in this
to be the people life of
the straight eight one or
reasonable people this area the role story
your building this is almost live in bed and
born again
and want to be more in
in cruiser dance party skating on to
make and or performance is that because
performance
he it content or is white pants of
temp people and and want to creating in
ikea not not about
wat de language or about van uw bazant
in which you see what some  part it costs
or how much experience  ence and white white to the
tempura
going into tingled fry a pen and make
something
so what rest of my a business
[Music]
her